I think the question everyone should be
asked you it's funny this is the
question I get a lot now because like
are like oh david seems like you figured
it out what you want to do and then
everyone's like I'm so unhappy my job
like I want to cook or like the question
you should ask you that was like are you
happy and like and am I how about I know
but like do what you want to do and I
and I go back to it like you're going to
be dead you have a very finite time on
this earth and no one's going to care
about what you do no one in Bosnia cares
about what you're doing or in China
cares about what you're doing as long as
you don't become you know pol pot or you
know we genocide do whatever you want
you know and I think that's the thing is
it's again cliches like do something you
like to do and that's I only say that
it's because like I recently have been
inundated with that questions like well
give me advice or whatever I don't know
myself I'm just trying to figure it out
too but I think you should kind of
constantly ask yourself why is this what
I want to be doing in my life you know
am I happy with it